now what you plan
I'll be your man surprise Crystal Stauss
and g-flip are married it feels great
the selling Sunset Stars rep confirmed
the happy news to E.T after she shared
this reel celebrating the release of
g-flip's new single Be Your Man the
video Chronicles their year-long
relationship
[Music]
and the surprise comes at the end in
this pick of the couple in what looks
like a private wedding ceremony
Crystal's caption love doesn't always go
as planned sometimes it's immeasurably
better
it's awesome that we get to celebrate
you know our love and our pride
krishelle and G flip first went public
with their romance last May after she
starred in the Australian singer steamy
music video for their song get me out of
here
we had so much fun on set like we still
like talk about that day and how much
fun we had the project came out nearly a
week after Chris Shell confirmed they're
a real life couple I recently have been
spending a lot of time with someone
that's very important to me their name
is Keith Webb I know being in this
position we get judged constantly yeah
but at the end of the day I I'm so happy
and so if if that angers someone then
that's not really my problem do you
think she's found the one are you trying
to Usher them into the married Club oh
if I could I would yeah I love them
together
um she's so happy she seems so in her
element and G is just amazing I've
honestly never seen chriselle like be so
in tune with who she is and just
comfortable yeah krishelle is selling
Sunset co-star Mary Fitzgerald totally
saw the two as end game they are the
best couple I'm so happy for both of
them and it looks like we'll see
chriselle and G Flip's romance Blossom
on season six of the hit Netflix series
I know people think I'm having a midlife
crisis but I'm having an Awakening
okay
but goals don't change ring that Bell
and cash
content coming for you guys very soon so
can you tease at least a little bit of
season six like what kind of words would
you would you use to describe it we all
need therapy
grab your tissues we're all going to
therapy after that there you go that's a
good team selling Sunset season six
drops May 19th on Netflix and fingers
crossed we'll see the footage behind
this dreamy snap
[Music]
please